Olá é possível prevenir ou até tratar
doenças da tireoide através da
alimentação sim é possível o que eu
quero que vocês entendam é que as
doenças da tiroide estão cada vez mais
comuns hoje em dia e você provavelmente
conhece alguém com algum problema
relacionado o mais comum deles é o
hipotiroidismo Provavelmente você
conhece não é então mesmo que você não
tenha qualquer disfunção na tireoide é
importante otimizar a função dela
prevenir problemas futuros para aqueles
que sofrem de doenças relacionadas a
tireoide como comum hipotiroidismo ou
bócio nódulos ou mesmo doença autoimune
como Hashimoto a tiroidite Hashimoto a
alimentação que eu vou sugerir será
fundamental pro controle e melhora dos
sintomas dessas doenças isso claro deve
ser combinado com tratamento que você já
está fazendo seja reposição hormonal
adequada vitaminas ou outros nutrientes
tudo isso vai convergir e agregar pra
melhora geral pessoal vou falar
especificamente de alimentos simples e
fáceis de incorporar no dia a dia eu
tentei selecionar os alimentos que são
mais fáceis de adquirir e com custo mais
acessível Existem muitos alimentos que
podem favorecer a saúde tiroidiana e
também nos hormônios como um todo mas eu
selecionei alguns especiais antes de
mencioná-los é importante entender
porque esses alimentos são relevantes
eles contêm nutrientes essenciais paraa
conversão do hormônio tiroidiano inativo
o T4 al levotiroxina na sua forma ativa
o T3 A triodotironina então esse
processo é fundamental para o
metabolismo e o funcionamento adequado
de vários sistemas do nosso corpo a
conversão do T4 em T3 ocorre de diversas
formas no fígado que precisa estar
saudável e no intestino que necessita de
um microbioma saudável para ajudar nesse
processo portanto precisamos de
alimentos que suportem que D suporte a
esse todo processo focando na tireoide
fígado e intestinos eu vou deixar na
descrição desse vídeo alguns outros
vídeos muito interessantes relacionados
a esse órgão tireoide então não deixem
de assistir porque todos esses vídeos
complemento que você está vendo agora
então vamos ao primeiro alimento nosso
primeiro alimento é o ovo alimento
acessível relativamente barato que todo
mundo tem em casa e por que que eu estou
falando do ovo Quando pensamos a
tireoide uma das primeiras coisas que
vem à mente é a ingestão de iodo que é
fundamental pra conversão dos hormônios
T4 em T3 e para a produção desses
hormônios em geral uma parte dos casos
de hipotiroidismo
hipotiroidismo ocorre simplesmente
porque as pessoas não ingerem odo de
forma suficiente na alimentação
a falta de odo pode também levar ao
desenvolvimento de bósio um inchaço na
parte frontal do pescoço devido ao
crescimento da glândula tireoide em uma
tentativa de compensar deficiência e
precisamos de pequenas doses de iodo
algo em torno de 150 a 300 mg por dia
Fontes ricas de odo incluem algas
marinhas como a alga al câ que pode
fornecer até 4200 MG de odo por uma
porção de 100 g peixes também contêm
quantidades significativas de odo
contudo nem todos têm acesso fácil a
algas ou podem consumi-las com
frequência mas pensando em alimentos
acessíveis para o dia a dia o ovo é uma
excelente opção cada ovo grande contém
aproximadamente 25 MG de iodo se você
comer quatro ovos por dia como eu faço
de manhã já estará ingerindo 100 mg de
iodo uma quantidade razoável você po
pode complementar essa ingestão com
outros alimentos e fontes de odo como
peixes o próprio sal marinho morangos
feijões agrião entre outros pessoal a
ingestão excessiva de odo também pode
ser um problema para tireóide
especialmente vindas de suplementos sem
acompanhamento médico o segundo alimento
é a castanha do Pará como muitos de
vocês sabem Ela é Rica em selênio o
selênio é um mineral muito importante
fundamental pro funcionamento da
tireoide pois ajuda na conversão do T4 e
T3 Além disso O selênio protege tireoide
contra inflamações que podem ocorrer
devido à exposição a poluentes toxinas a
que todos nós somos expostos todos os
dias para pessoas com doenças autoimunes
da tireoide como a tiroidite de
Hashimoto principal causa de
hipotiroidismo há estudos mostrando que
o selênio pode diminuir a inflamação da
tireoide reduzir os anticorp corpos da
doença e até ajudar a colocá-la em
remissão a tiroidite em remissão
deixando a doença
Adormecida portanto para mim O selenio é
um elemento é um mineral fundamental
falando de alimentação a castanho do
Pará é uma das fontes mais ricas em
selênio ou castanho do Brasil como é
conhecido internacionalmente a dose
diária recomendada de selênio é pequena
cerca de 55 microg por dia mas para uma
saúde izada da tireoide uma dose entre
100 e 200 mg ao dia de selênio já é
ideal a concentração de Selen na
castanha do Pará pode variar Bastante
dependendo da região de origem e das
condições climáticas de solo uma única
Castanha pode ter entre 30 a 100 mg de
selênio para não exagerar e também não
consumir menos do que o necessário você
pode comer de duas a três castanhas do
Pará por dia isso já é suficiente paraa
maioria das pessoas
lembre-se de que o ovo também é muito
bom em selênio carnes feijão bananas
repolho também complementam a quantidade
de áa necessária Eu recomendo que você
compre a castanha do Brasil ou do Pará
inteira com casca sabe que ela casca bem
dura que é difícil até de quebrar isso é
importante porque evita contaminações
por fungos e outras toxinas que podem
ocorrer quando a castanha fica muito
tempo estocada ou armazenada
o terceiro alimento são as carnes e os
Miúdos principalmente o fígado estamos
falando de alimentos de origem animal e
por quê a carne o frango e o fígado de
boi são ricos em zinco e ferro muitas
pessoas com problemas de tireoide
especialmente as mulheres tem uma
necessidade maior de ferro e às vezes
apresentam ferritina baixa a tireide
precisa de Ferro para funcionar
adequadamente assim como precisa de
zinco por exemplo o zinco é necessário
para ativar os receptores de hormônios
tiroidianos no órgão cerebral hipotálamo
no caso do zinco e do ferro a
biodisponibilidade é alta em alimentos
de origem animal o zinco também é
importante ele é abundante em frutos do
mar mas nem todos têm acesso a Ostras
Camarões de forma regular e você incluir
carne seja bovina frango ou fígado de
boi na sua dieta estará fornecendo ao
seu corpo uma boa quantidade de zinco e
ferro por exemplo 100 g de carne moída
contém cerca de 5 mg de zinco enquanto
85 g de fígado de boi cozido tem 4,5 MG
de zinco e 2,7 MG de Ferro Além disso o
ovo novamente o ovo esse alimento
incrível também contém zinco agora se
você é vegetariano ou vegano precisará
incluir mais alimentos vegetais ricos em
zinco na sua dieta nesse caso recomendo
adicionar sementes de abóbora ou de
gergelin a sua dieta diária pois são
boas fontes de zinco o próximo item são
duas
especiarias a cúrcuma e o cominho Preto
a cúrcuma ou mais popularmente conhecido
como açafrão açafrão da Índia açafrão da
terra tem uma potente ação
antiinflamatória que pode ajudar
diretamente acalmar a inflamação na
tireoide no intestino e otimizar a
função do fígado o o princípio ativo da
cúrcuma curcumina é o que proporciona
essas excelentes propriedades
antiinflamatórias se você adicionar
cúrcuma como tempero em diversos
alimentos como arroz carnes e ovos se
possível acrescente um pouco de pimenta
preta que contém piperina para aumentar
a absorção da curcumina outra especiaria
que pode ser útil é o cominho Preto a
nigela Sativa conhecido também por suas
propriedades antiinflamatórias e
antioxidantes Especialmente benéficas
para quem tem a tiroidite rimoto o
cominho preto foi capaz de diminuir os
níveis de anticorpos relacionados à
doença autoimune tiroidite rimoto
principal causa de hipotiroidismo
melhorando também as concentrações do
hormônio ti rodiano ativo T3 o cominho
preto pode ser combinado com a cúrcuma
para melhor absorção de curcumina e
potencialização dos efeitos dos dois
condimentos pessoal o próximo alimento
são as verduras verdes e amargas esses
vegetais como rúcula agrião escarola e
almeirão são indiretamente muito
interessantes para a saúde da tireoide
comer esses alimentos amargos ativa as
papilas gustativas estimulando a
produção de enzimas digestivas e o fluxo
biliar também promovendo uma melhor
digestão uma boa digestão essencial para
absorver todos os nutrientes necessários
para manter a função da tireoide
saudável quanto melhor a digestão mais
nutrient Seu Corpo Pode absorver Além
disso comer verduras amargas promove a
desintoxicação natural do fígado lembra
que eu comentei que para converter e
manter os hormônios tiroidianos de forma
adequada precisamos de um fígado
saudável e também de um intestino
funcionando bem as verduras amargas
contribuem para isso um fígado saudável
regula o colesterol equilibra os
hormônios desintoxica o sangue e
metaboliza melhor os nutrientes da nossa
alimentação O que é fundamental paraa
fabricação e conversão dos hormônios
tiroidianos então inclua diariamente uma
porção dessas verduras na sua dieta
então você pode variar um dia você
consome uma salada de grião no outro uma
salada de rúcula ou faça escarola ou
almeirão
refogados o próximo Na verdade são
também dois alimentos para melhorar a
saúde intestinal esses alimentos são
caldo de ossos e o chucrute no começo Eu
mencionei que precisamos de um intestino
saudável para produzir os hormônios
tiroidianos de maneira adequada certo e
esses dois alimentos vão ajudar nisso o
cald de ossos é um alimento que ajuda a
curar o intestino ele contém nutrientes
que podem atuar na reparação e
reconstrução da barreira intestinal que
é frequentemente danificada por tudo de
ruim que comemos que fazemos no nosso
dia a dia muitas vezes essa barreira
intestinal danificada é o começo de uma
doença tiroidiana especialmente doenças
autoimunes como é o caso da famosa
tiroidite rimoto o caldo de ossos Ajuda
a fortalecer a barreira intestinal e
acalmar a inflamação eu tenho vídeo
exclusivo sobre Como fazer caldo de
ossos onde eu ensino passo a passo então
não deixe de conferir esse vídeo na
descrição e o Chucrute o chucrute é
feito de repolho fermentado e é um
alimento probiótico os alimentos
fermentados estimulam e ajudam o nosso
microbioma intestinal então eles ajudam
a restabelecer essas bactérias que
trabalham na fabricação de
neurotransmissores vitaminas e hormônios
ajudam também na nossa defesa a maioria
das doenças de tireoide tem origem
autoimune A tiroid ashimoto então se
você tem problemas na tireoide as
chances são muito grandes de que também
tenha problemas intestinais mesmo que
você não sinta nada mesmo que você não
tenha diarreia ou constipação o chucrute
é um alimento fermentado que promove a
saúde intestinal ele é barato você pode
fazer em casa você só precisa comprar um
repolho e
fermentáveis de sementes óleos de soja
milho canola e girassol glúten alimentos
Ultra processados e fast food não
precisa ser radical Mas tente manter a
alimentação mais limpa possível reduzir
o açúcar ao máximo também é crucial e é
importante equilibrar essas mudanças com
o que você consegue dentro do seu
orçamento e conforto não adianta ser
radical e prejudicar a sua saúde
emocional comece aos poucos mas sempre
siga em frente vai aprimorando aos
poucos compartilhe os vídeos faça bem a
vida de alguém pode mudar também no
[Música]
canal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
você é feira